we've been sort of theorizing about how
dumb Donald Trump is and by dumb I mean
just sort of general knowledge we
figured out that after a year of
campaigning on health insurance he might
have the entire time actually been
thinking that it was life insurance we
speculated he might not have been aware
that Puerto Ricans were citizens until
someone told him hey you know these are
American citizens during the fall out
after the multiple hurricanes that hit
the Puerto Rican Island Trump's lack of
knowledge about what a blind trust is
was evident in the lead-up to his
inauguration how does the stock market
work how does money work is a strong or
weak dollar good for us something he
called Michael Flynn about at 3:00 a.m.
at one point
why didn't hurricane victims just get
away from the storm and their private
helicopters whatever right there's a
range of different questions we've
speculated as to Donald Trump's
knowledge on Donald Trump claimed over
the weekend
while speaking to a hate group that he
met with the president of the Virgin
Islands of course there is no such
person or I guess there is it's Donald
Trump himself the the President of the
United States is the president of the
Virgin Islands effectively here is
Donald Trump at this horrible hate group
rally take a look we also stand with the
millions of people who have suffered
from the massive fires which are right
now raging in California and a
catastrophic hurricanes along the Gulf
Coast in Puerto Rico the Virgin Islands
and I will tell you I left Texas and I
left Florida and I left Louisiana and I
went to Puerto Rico and I met with the
president of the Virgin Islands these
are people that are incredible people
they've suffered gravely some of those
people are literally incredible in the
sense that they don't exist and we
shouldn't believe in them like this
other guy or gal who supposedly is the
President of the United States Virgin
Islands now how did the Trump
administration deal with this bogus and
embarrassing statement by Trump well
they corrected the transcript so that it
would say governor instead of president
after the fact they wrote the White
House released a transcript where it
says I left Florida and I left Louisiana
and I went to Puerto Rico and I met with
the president is crossed out
governor has been inserted of the Virgin
Islands every single joke about Donald
Trump becomes the truth two weeks ago I
joked Donald Trump should demand the
resignation of the President of Puerto
Rico over his terrible handling of the
recent hurricanes and now Trump actually
says I met with the president of the US
Virgin Islands in the context of
hurricane relief
I spoke with myself about disaster
relief because I'm doing great things
for these poor people or something like
that here's Donald explaining why he's
the guy to go to with any issue we have
because he's such a smart guy and I was
a good student I understand things I
comprehend very well okay better than I
think almost anybody and I want to tell
you I listened to a bunch of stuff last
night on television that was disgraceful
it was disgraceful he listened to a
whole bunch of stuff something is very
wrong here beyond just being an
uninformed dude born with a silver spoon
in his mouth right remember when it
would have been surprising if the
president said something this dumb the
simpler times of is our children
learning and binders full of women or
what's Aleppo what what is that what's
Aleppo those were simpler quaint times
where now we are dealing with a whole
new level of incompetence and stupidity
from the President of the United States